Congratulations on completing inferential statistics. We really hope you've
enjoyed this course. You now have the skills you
need to analyze your very own dataset and make
accurate predictions. Now you're ready to move on to your
final project, where you'll perform your own statistical analysis
on a dataset. With your selected data set, you'll
investigate a hypothesis of your choice, and present your
findings in a short report. This report will include visualizations,
descriptive statistics, test results, and an interpretation of
what you've found. If you're looking for what
course to go to next, maybe try out
our introduction to data science class or introduction
to computer science if you want to expand
your programming knowledge. Both of these classes are
linked in the instructor's notes box. Either way,
we really look forward to seeing you again soon.